フェちゃい者 b はい違う a ちゃいず
あれめちゃイエーイッどうもはじめですマジというわけでお久しぶりでもないですけど
も実はですねサビさんに静岡に帰って来ましたはじめしゃちょーでございます俺はここ
付間ずっと富山県で仕事をしてい
たちょっとした時間のないんだか動画撮ってるんですけどもあの簡潔にまとめ4
特技が欲しいそう私独自の欲しいんですよまあなんか遊戯王カードとか
ポケモンカードとかパズドラモンスト住み特にまでがないけど住みたいのはたくさん
あるんですけどもあの
ああああああ
使え使えるわけじゃないで大切なコミュニケーションツールあの側夢中になってて
頑張れるものとして菅僕の持つ分の上がりにはつながっているんですけどもあの使え
あまり困難階地上生活でばすごい
そんなこともできるんだみたいのではなんないんですよねということばっかしてた結果
私には徳井が一切なく
まぁちょっとピアノが弾けるくらいでしょ
はほとんどできることもないくイベントに行ってもイベントとかでだんだん場とか
ステージに乗っても
残念ながら私初めてつを
やることが
ないそうなんですやることがないんですごく歌も歌えないダンスボって来ない面白い
ことも言えない
はっはっは
あの僕のできることといえばヘラヘラと何か僕が個人的に好きな動画を取ることぐらい
しかできないんですよ大問題です実際大問題なんですよ
you best が入ってもない
何も出来ないと言うけど別に何かステージの上で何か出来るになりたいとじゃないん
ですけども
こんな使えるえっすごいはじめ結婚してみたいなとくぎが欲しいと思いましてあの何か
こう討議を身に付けようかなと思っております
カッコカリよかったらコメント欄にですね私肇社長ができたらかっこいいとかなんか
男の子愛をはじめがこれできたら尊敬するわみたいなのを書いてください
コメント欄でお願いします女子の女の子の皆さんも弾み撮影ができたらマジでカッコ
イイみたいな僕がそのトッピングってきた法令そうなものをぜひコメント欄で書いて
くださいまあどうにするかもしれないしそのコメント欄のちょっと様子を見
ていいなと思ったやつがあったらそれを趣味にしようと思いますなぁあの個人的に本当
にあの
興味ないんですよ興味ないことで興味ないんでコメント欄を見て興味を沸かせられたら
できると思って力込めてなんで皆さんが外れ社長の身につけたらよい東方特技
変えてくださいよろしくお願いします本当その域になればマジってやろうと思ってるん
だよねだけでぜひ皆さんコメント欄に書いてください
me
そして何よりバンディーズ復活おめでとじゃあ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ